what is the easiest way to generate some
quick clients it's a question that came
in from a youtube viewer chris d
and chris is watching all my videos love
you chris thank you for that solid
advice
and wrote in what is your opinion on the
easiest way to generate some quick
clients so here it is the easiest way
partnerships
the easiest way to generate clients if
you don't have any clients you're trying
to bring on new clients your business
the easiest way to do it is to partner
up
find somebody who's also selling to your
target market
and find a way to work together
look at where your customers are going
to before they buy from you and after
they buy from you and find a way to work
with those companies
i'm not saying go to your direct
competition
but go to the people around them go to
the people in your industry who you
could form a working relationship with
and set up a partnership agreement so
they're not only a piece of your
business
but they're helping promote you
some people will do this
through
a referral type of commission so you
know you give them x percent of any
leads that they bring in some people
will do it just because it's a value add
to their customers because they want to
be able to pass their good customers
onto somebody who they know is going to
do good work that's the fastest way to
get going it's a faster way to bring on
new customers because they're getting
referred by somebody who they trust
you're working with
partners who already have your target
audience and have a relationship with
them
so when they say you have to go talk
to chris d
then they're going to listen and they're
going to come to you and instead of
having to close customers individually
you're closing out groups of customers
because as soon as somebody makes that
referral their that customer is already
pre-sold they want to work with you you
have to convince them still you got to
do some you got to show that you can
back up all the claims that are made
about you but these guys want to work
with you when i first started my
software company
we had a hard time getting started we
had a hard time bringing on customers i
felt like
felt like things should be moving faster
i felt like we had great talent and
skill a great product why is this taking
so long you know i was pulling out 300
bucks a month
at the start 300 bucks it wasn't enough
to survive and it got so
frustrating
and i thought there has to be a faster
way there has to be an easier way like
this should not be so hard i write the
book saw the videos all about
entrepreneurship it looks so easy and
yet i'm i'm the stupid one who can't
figure this thing out
and i looked at companies like microsoft
and how they got started and it was
through partnerships
they partnered up their big deal was
with when they partnered with ibm and
they said every ibm that goes out has
microsoft software on it so instead of
selling to consumers one at a time at a
time at a time at a time they partnered
up with one company who was able to sell
tons of software for them
so i used that strategy put it to work
for my business as well and i started
making partnerships and i started
reaching out to distributors and all
sorts of different companies who are
related to my industry
i found them online i did a google
search i went looking for related
businesses
and i gave them an incentive
most of them were a commission based i
gave them incentive to sell our product
and some people paid in advance
and after
you know a year of struggling and not
being able to make this work within my
first month of china partnership
strategy i landed a deal with a company
in europe who paid me thirteen thousand
dollars
as a fee to be our exclusive partner for
certain markets in europe
thirteen thousand dollars
now that may not be a lot to you guys
right now but you know i'm making 300
bucks a month that's what i'm pulling
out i'm i'm not able to survive 13 000
that was a lifeline that saved me
that that gave me not only cash but
momentum energy like hey this can work
finally something that works something
that can help me grow
a strategy to build around
and i took that and just applied it
again and again and again and again and
made tons of partnerships and we became
the default company for a lot of these
businesses to pass leads onto
so it's the fastest way to do it because
you're not going after customers one at
a time and these guys already have a
base
they already have your market in their
hands they just have to say trust these
guys
so go start making partnerships
it will change your business
and give you an easy
quick way
to generate new customers like you're
asking
believe
if you guys like this video thumbs up
below thank you so much and i want to
hear what you have to say please leave a
comment below if you have a question
leave it in the comment section i'll do
a video response for you just like this
one thank you guys i'll see you soon
you